more than 40% of tickets sold for the
Cricket World Cup being held here have
been bought by fans of South Asian
origin cheering on other countries in
1990 Lord Emmett implied the Britons who
supported the countries of their ethnic
origin instead of England were not
sufficiently integrated but today there
is little suggestion supporting another
team conflicts of being proudly British
in fact our cricketing authorities
openly admit they want to convert the
huge interest from British South Asian
fans into developing the England stars
of the future now identities are
multiple Britain may choose to support
England in football Pakistan in cricket
and Team GB in the Olympics this is
similar to a French dual national here
supporting the French team over ours in
the football World Cup at least because
they won the world is a lot more complex
than tenets test allows for and don't
even get me started on my mixed British
Pakistani American via Essex Sun born in
Tennessee but living in London though if
he grows up to call it soccer instead of
football I'll just have to tell him that
that just ain't cricket I agree with you
entirely especially on the soccer thing
with you and I do think that people are
little bits of everything these days
what I do think there is if you scratch
beneath the surface it does worry me
slightly when you look at things like
the British attitude survey and you ask
people do you feel English for example
and there's an interesting statuses I
proud to be English and if you look at
the younger people 18 to 24 year olds
only 45% of those are so whilst I think
yes it's fine to you know be mixed
identity and support different things I
wonder if there is this slide under
Curran which is reflective in some of
these things where people are not
feeling fully integrated in England and
feeling you know identifying and power
to be British and if that is the case
and some of these stats would show it is
and that for me is slightly concerning
what yeah absolutely I mean I I recently
declared myself English many people were
confused I'm clearly not anglo-saxon I'm
not white English in that in that
original British
well I think I'm both I think I'm
introducing probably Essex and he's from
Bosnia and I asked him this question the
other day and he was actually really
I said who would you support in the
format and it was actually quite
troubled by it
and he said because he's
first-generation immigrant so he didn't
leave Bosnia so it was like 28 he said
if it was a football match I have to
support boys no he said but if it was
England against anywhere else at
anything else he says it's not about he
thinks integration isn't about he said
it's about what you feel you know he
said to be he wanted to be a good
British citizen but he didn't apply for
his British passport until five years
after he'd been here because he didn't
feel he deserved it or unwarranted it
because he thinks it's about working
being a good citizen
do you know giving something back so he
waited five or six years he was eligible
with just after the World Cup
Olympic it's a very complicated thing
but he said if you were a third
generation immigrant you would probably
support Britain and everything you know
I think I couldn't believe my went a bit
and that's the cricket test but I had to
go back into the to wiki to see it was
an actual thing that's right I thought
it was just something I think it's
incredibly devices but I think sport is
incredibly unifying and today we saw
mosula
and you know there are now chance I
won't do it but they go moso lalalalala
you know if he's good he's good enough
for me if he scores another few I'll be
a Muslim too people's love and
admiration for footballers of foreign
nationalities and I think in the last
World Cup squad in 2018
11
out of the 23 players were of ethnic yes
origin so what's happening is is that
people actually they're defeating
Islamophobia they're defeating racism by
actually playing the game and being you
know you know purporting here at health
secretary Matt Hancock agrees with you
let's have a look at yeah
[Music]
it's the Cricket World Cup and everybody
can get involved so let's get active
tickets does anyone here have the Matt
Hancock at Rachel sport is a tremendous
way to bring people together we had to
check it it's not as if sadly and you
better you know better than most we're
not yet a land of milk and honey for
someone with a different skin color or a
different face so we have to bear that
in mind what I find intriguing though is
that politicians will seize moments like
this to suddenly show that they're men
of the people to do what he does and
they have to play together but no of
course what you say I sense again we're
all in violent agreement most dangerous
well actually 45 I think it's 45% if I
can just check that 41% of all ticket
sales went to South Asian fans but
there's an opportunity here because we
have Moines who plays for our team and
actually if the if the Cricket Board for
England and Wales were to see that as an
opportunity to tap into world talent we
could end up with as this happened in
football more of these British South
Asians who actually only three percent
of the domestic games of tickets are
bought by them so they're not involved
on the domestic level and that's pretty
quickly they're not involved in the
domestic level it's an opportunity yes I
was thinking in Pakistan game and what
that and knowing you are gonna do this
topic I mean I saw the crowd differently
because you couldn't assume that people
who look Pakistan with supporting
Pakistan I think that's but it's
interesting what Tebbit said was his
cricket test of loyalty suggested
migration is preferable from countries
who were on our side in World War two
Prince Harry he's got a word about as
well the first
Cricket World Cup took place in England
in 1975 and I'm delighted that the UK
will once again play host to this
wonderful
global sporting event featuring ten
incredible teams who thanks to the UK's
cultural diversity will feel as though
they are competing in front of a home
crowd every time they take to the field
there you go I must say I've been to you
all to watch cook at about five times
now and I still got no clue